[Music]
welcome to your weekly ticket
a willy wonka prequel is in the works
warner brothers is preparing for a third
movie which will be helmed by paddington
director paul king
this time around the film will be a
prequel called wonka which will
dive deeper into the backstory of how
young willy wonka became a candy company
and how he met the oompa loompas
which we did learn a little bit about
through johnny depp's charlie and the
chocolate factory
as for who will play wonka this time
around early casting rumors suggest
timothy chalamet
and tom holland are among those
potentially being eyed for the role
let them fight after a nearly year-long
delay due to the ongoing covet 19
pandemic
godzilla vs kong is finally here
but the fourth monsterverse movie
definitely packs a punch with tons of
monster action for fans to look forward
to
the film is directed by adam wingard
with a script from pirates of the
caribbean writer terry rozio
in addition to the titular behemoths it
stars alexander skarsgard
millie bobby brown rebecca hall and
brian tyree henry
you'll finally be able to see the film
in theaters on march 26th
and searchlight pictures has updated its
2021 release
calendar which includes guillermo del
toro's nightmare alley which is now set
for release on december 3rd
this is the first film that del toro has
directed since winning best director and
best picture at the 2017 oscars for
the shape of water nightmare alley is
based off the 1946 novel of the same
name by william lindsey gresham which is
a carnival set mystery
involving a famous mind reading act this
new adaptation has an a-list cast which
includes bradley cooper
cate blanchett rooney mara willem dafoe
richard jenkins
and tony collette to name a few
today we're celebrating the release of
the little things being available to
watch in theaters on friday by
talking to the film's cast denzel
washington jared leto and rami malek
take a look at what they had to say to
fandango correspondent nikki novak
about how a surprising amount of improv
went into shaping their roles
you wouldn't think that a movie like
this would have a lot of improv and yet
that we've heard that it did
even including jared you singing
somewhere over the rainbow at one point
to denzel's character
so i wanted to ask first i'll ask denzel
how does
improv inform how did it inform your
performance in this movie and are you a
fan of improv
i never really improvised before i work
with spike or not to that degree
as i did on mobetta blues there's a
place for it sometimes
and you and you try it it may work it
may not work but uh
i'm all for it if it fits what did you
learn about your character when you were
improvising i know you really got to go
over the top and learn things but how
did it inform your performance
well i think humor is always a great
place to
you know uh experiment with improv
because
you know i always think about jokes or
like it's like an open avocado it only
lasts for so long before it gets brown
you know it's you know so surprise is
good with humor
and um so i found that pretty useful
uh because it suited the character like
denzel said if it
if it's appropriate then then it's great
it uh you can also
you know ruin a scene uh if it goes off
the rails too much but
i'm quite a big fan of it when when the
opportunity arises
so what was the moment that it went off
the rails was it the somewhere over the
rainbow or was there something even
wilder that maybe ended up even on the
cutting edge i don't know maybe it was
when i talked about potato skins i'm not
sure
really did that actually mommy yeah
ronnie
there
did that happen and rami what did you
learn about i know you've obviously
watched
these two actors perform before but
performing opposite them
in those moments in those improv moments
and even in the scripted moments what
did you learn about your cast mates as
performers well it's it's exactly what
you're talking about in reference to
improv it may not uh always be literal
but
every time you stepped in a scene you
just don't know what's going to happen
and i think that's such a great form of
improvisation
and you know you only get that with some
of the finest actors so
that's what i experienced what was the
moment that surprised you
every moment you work with these two
guys is going to be
surprising i i don't think i could walk
in on set
and tell you what denzel or what jared
was gonna do in any given moment
and i think that's really evident in the
film and i think that's evident when i
watched it i had no idea where it was
going
and you don't want to blame because you
don't want to miss anything so thank the
three of you i get a lot of award
screeners and this is among my favorites
so thank you all very much
thank you so much
also available to watch in theaters on
friday is saint maude
i have a responsibility oh yes of course
this is life and death on another level
mod played by morphed clark is a newly
devout hospice nurse who becomes
obsessed with saving her dying patient's
soul
but sinister forces and her own sinful
past threatened to put an
end to her holy calling the film which
marks the feature film debut for writer
director rose glass is currently
certified fresh with a 97 on the tomato
meter
[Music]
and available to watch at home on friday
is savage
hey none of us are angels probably the
opposite
we wouldn't be gangsters if we always
did what we were told
why do you wear that mask
so you can see who i am
inspired by the true stories of new
zealand's street gangs across 30 years
savage follows dany at three defining
moments in his life
from the abusive state-run boys
institutions of the 60s
to the emerging urban gang scene in the
70s where disenfranchised teenagers
created their own families on the
streets
to the 80s when gangs became more
structured and violent
together the three chapters of dany's
life combined to create a deeper look at
a boy
who grows up to become the brutal
enforcer of a gang
alright well that's it for today but
leave us a comment and let us know what
you'll be watching this week
i'm kale and i'll see you next time
[Music]